Build it, Draw it, Play it!
Vsauce! This is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people. This
is BiDiPi!
Build it
Artist Zheng Chunhui made this world record
longest continuous wooden sculpture. It's
a replica of the famous painting Along the
River During The Qingming Festival and it
took four years to create and is about 12
meters long, 3 meters tall, and 2.4 meters
wide.
Henry Hargreaves and Caitlin Levin created
these gingerbread replicas of well known art
museums from around the world including the
Tate Modern in London, The Louvre in Paris
and The Guggenheim in New York. All of the
candy was from Dylan's Candy Bar where they
were asked to create something unique for
an art show.
Yayoi Kusama created these Infinity Rooms
for a show called "I Who Have Arrived in Heaven."
They're mirrored environments that trick the
eye and create an unusual viewing experience
and they're so popular that the wait to view
the rooms can be anywhere from 1 to 4 hours.
The artist, now in her mid 80's, is also showing
off 27 large scale paintings.
Draw it
Shanti Grumbine creates intricate art using
the New York Times. The work is called Kenosis,
which is a greek noun for emptiness or emptying.She
takes headlines such as Tropical Storm Irene,In
the Midst of Losses,and Bin Laden's Secret
Life and turns them into something new by
removing parts of the image and story.
Dino Tomic of Atomic Circus sent me these
amazing hyper realistic large scale mixed
media drawings of his family that include
his father, mother, grandfathers, andgrandmothers.
Each one took over 70 hours to create and
he used water-based colored pencils, dry pastel,
and tattoo color.
And now for the incredible drawings from the
YouTube channel of Marcello Barenghi.
Tal Peleg is a makeup artist whose canvas
is the human eye. Her work includes a wide
range of themes such as this steam punk style,Rudolph
the Red-Nosed Reindeer, sushi, the ugly duckling,
Pink Floyd's the wall, and a cat playing with
yarn.
Play it
Tyler Freeman created Drum Pants - a wearable
sensor that turns your clothes into
a drum kit.
Chicago's Magical Piano was set up by Amtrak
and Rob Bliss Creative to respond to commuters
passing by.
Here's Julien playing the drums for a wikidrummer
dot com in a range of settings showcasing
how different locations affect the sound.
Finally here's the official video for Security
by Sega Bodega created by Adoxo.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube. Or share them with everyone
over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio. Music created and submitted
by you guys. Also checkout Your BiDiPi - an
entire video dedicated to only your creations.
And as always - thanks for watching!